[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم الى حصاد الليله معكم ليلى في
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل
اخرى هذه اللقطات تاتي مباشره من مجلس
الامن في نيويورك حيث تبدا الان جلسه
مغلقه بشان تطورات في الاراضي الفلسفيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد الليله
مشهد التصعيد في مزيدا من ردود الفعل رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيليه يقول ان هجمات
المستوطنين
فمنا باهظا ويتعهد بالتحقيق فيها والجيش
يغلق مداخل مدن لملاحقه منافذ عمليات
حواره واريحا ويكشف عن مناورات الاحد في
الضفه وفي مقابله مع جزيره الوضع كارثي
بالضفه ويؤكد ضروره الالتزام بتفاهمات
العقبه
ضخمت على ابواب الحسم بعد تاكيد قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه صعوبه الوضع اثر
تطبيق المدينه
تتحدث عن تقدم شمالي المدينه الاستراتيجيه
وقوات المواليه لروسيا في دنيا تقول
كل الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه باتت في
مرمى نيرانها
مسؤولون امريكيون يتهمون شركه صينيه بدعم
ميليشيا بصور اقمار اصطناعيه وفي تمددا
لمساحه التنافس الروسي
يتحرك في الفضاء السوفيتي السابق ويلتقي
مسؤوليه
ويطالب بموقف واضح من العقوبه على روسيا
ونضرب في اذربيجان للتوجه الاجتماعي
مجموعه 20
ينتقل الى التكنولوجيا تيك توك وهواوي في
مرمى اتهامات متبادله بين واشنطن البيت
الابيض يحضر استخدام التطبيق الصيني على
الموظفين الفيدراليين بسبب مخاوف امنيه
وتتجه لتقييد تصدير معدات لشركه هواوي
تتهمها بتوظيف مفهوم الامن القومي في مجال
التنافس التجاري
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الجدل الدائر حول تيك توك
على هواتف موظفي الاتحاد لاسباب الامنيه
فيما وجه البيت الابيض امرا للوكالات
الفيدراليه بحظر تطبيق خلال شهر من على
هواتف موظفها وذلك لحتى
ترد الصين على هذه الاتهامات بوصف موقف
الامريكي بانه محاوله لتعميم مفهوم الامن
القومي وقمع الشركات
الاستطلاع ارائكم بشكل هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم هذا السؤال برايكم هل تعتقدون
ان تطبيق تيك توك بشكل تهديدا لان
المؤسسات عبر استخدام الموظفين له
النتيجه جاءت على نحو
68% قبل نعم في حين راى نحو 32% ان
التطبيق لا يهدد امن المؤسسات
طبعا
على منصات العراقيه يمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز الذي يظهر الان
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد الى ايضا
ملفنا الخاص بانعكاسات اقليميه للتوتر في
شرق اسيا نرصد تحول اليابان بين عقيدتين
عسكريتين عين على الصين واخرى على انفاق
دفاعي يرتفع
[موسيقى]
وفي حوار خاص مع الجزيره اكد منسق
والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القوميه الامريكي
تشجب العنف في الاراضي الفلسفيه
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تعتبر المستطاعات عقبه
امام السلام وقال كربي ان الرئيس بايدن
يعتقد ان حل الدولتين هو طريق التوصلي
للسلام بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
كان واضحا تماما حول ابتسامنا بحل
الدولتين وقد حاجز بهذا القول ليس فقط
الخاصه
ايضا الوزير بلينكز ايضا ابقى على هذه
العمليه مستمره على الصعيد الدبلوماسي
المتحده تستمر
في دعمها لحل الدوله نعتقد ان هذا هو
السبيل الامثل ليس فقط الفلسطينيه
والاسرائيليه للمنطقه تكون طبعا لدينا
موقف حول المستوطنات باعتبار عقبه امام
السلام
وكلنا يجب ان يعمل
سويه لنمضي قدر الامام سنبقى ملتزمين بهذا
ونحث
ملتزمين لذلك بقدر متساوي
وكان الممثل الامريكي الخاص لشؤون
الفلسطينيه هاديه عمرو دان اعمال العنف
والتخريب التي تعرض لها اهالي
مدينه نابلس على يد مستوطنين
نشره مكتب الشؤون الفلسطينيه في السفاره
الامريكيه في القدس دعا عمرو هادي الى
محاسبه ومقادات جميع المسؤولين عن هجمات
المستوطنين التي وصفها بالشنيعه وغير
المقبوله كما طالب بتعويض الفلسطينيين
الذين تضررت ممتاركتهم واعرب عن تعازيه في
مقتل الشاب الفلسطيني
وممتلكات اهاليها واستمع الى شهادات
المواطنين فلسطينيين تعرضوا الاعتداءات
المستوطنين الذين هاجموا البلده بحمايه من
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انتقاما لقتل
مسلح فلسطيني مستوطنين
الحديث عن ثمن باهظ هذا بحسب رئيس اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي قال ان الاحداث الاخيره كبدت اسرائيل
اثمانا كبيره هل الذي تحدث عن العمليات
والاحداث الاخيره وقال ان الجيش يجري
تحقيقا بشانها ويدرسها متوعدا باحباط ما
وصفه بالارهاب ايا كانت انواع والعمل
بالوسائل العملياتيه
والاستخباراتيه كافه في سبيل القاء القبض
على المنوفي
يحقق في اعمال البلطجه الخطيره التي وقعت
فيها حواره بشكل عميق ايضا
في وقت يواصل فيه جيش الاسرائيلي فرض طوق
امير مشدد على منطقه اريحا عقب مقتل
مستوطن في اطلاق نار بمنطقه الاغوار جنوب
البحريه قوات الاحتلال نشرت حواجز عسكريه
في محيط المدينه وعززت قواتها بحثا عن
منثري هجوم الاثنين بينما قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي قوه الامن تواصل العمل على
كافه المستويات العسكريه والمخابرات بحثا
عن منافذه عمليه اطلاق النار في منطقه
حواره في وفي الاغوار جنوب رائحه
في سياق هذه المقاربه الاميه للجيش
الاسرائيلي يخرج وزير الامن الداخليه
مطالبا بتغيير ما سماه مفهوم الامن
والانتقال من الدفاع الى الهجوم واضاف ذلك
في تغريده على تويتر انه لن يكون هناك
احتواء بل يد ضاربه على الحديث
انعكاسات التصعيد الامير الاسرائيلي تظهر
اثارها سريعا على الارض حيث اعتقل ثمانيه
فلسطينيين على الاقل في بلده عبد في جنين
واخرين في مخيم العروب في الخليل جاء ذلك
بعد اقتحام مخيم شعفاط في القدس واعتقال
المحتله فقد هدمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منزلا بحجه البناء دون ترخيص
كذلك اقتحمت في ماده العيساويه شمال شقيق
القدس المحتله
منزلا ثم شرعت جرافه في هدم المنزل بحجه
عدم حصول صاحبه على ترخيص للبناء
ومعنى الان تل ابيب
كبير
وابدا معك من تصريح رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي من ان اسرائيل
كتبدت ثمن باهضا بسبب الاحداث الاخيره كيف
كان هناك 14 اسرائيليا قتلوا منذ بدايه
هذه السنه
وخمسه واربعين
منذ موجه الارهاب الفلسطيني الذي بدا قبل
سنه
وفي شهر رمضان وشعبان
حسب التقويم الاسلامي
وانا اعلم بانه كان عدد كبير لفلسطيني
لكن معظمهم كان المقاتلين كان ارهابيين
كانوا يهاجمون الناس جانب الاسرائيلي
تقريبا جميعهم كانوا مدنيين
هذه سنه فقط واحد منهم كانت جنديه وقد
عندما كان
رئيس الاركان يلمح الى ثمن من نوع اخر
الثمن الذي يتعلق بالتنديد الدولي على
مستوى الشعوب على مستوى الاعلام كذلك
توجه كثير من الشباب الذين كانوا محايدين
في الضفه للالتحاق بمجموعات مسلحه الا يعد
هذا ربما فشل استراتيجي
للطريقه التي تعاملت بها اسرائيل مع
الاحداث خصوصا مع الوجود الكبير ورغم ذلك
تقول هذه الاعداد وهذه الخسائر
نعم هذا امر لابد ان ننتظر لنرى نتائج
فقد كان فان رئيس كان الجيش الاسرائيلي
كان يطرح التلفزيون الاسرائيلي هذه الليله
وقد قال بان بعض
ربما لم تنجح
فقط
مختلفه انهاء موجه العنف هذه وقد اتخذت
ادت الخطط
في رمضان لتحسين ظروف حياه الفلسطينيين
وتسابي للعمل وتسهيل اي ظروف العمل او
تقييد عليهم لكن اذا حصلت مزيد ولكن
اليست ايضا حدث بسبب اطلاق اليد من
نتنياهو
الادريكفيرش بهذه الطريقه هل يمكن القول
ان السحر انقلب على الساحر ان ربما متضرر
بشكل كبير هو الحكومه الاسرائيليه الان
وبسبب هذا التوجه
وهو قد اشتكى بانه
الامنيه يوم امس وهناك
الجيش الاسرائيلي وضع تاكيد
الاشتباك عند فتح النار كلا
كاي تصعيد السبب هو بسبب السلطه
الفلسطينيه فقط السيطرتها على في الضفه
الغربيه على مواطنيها بما يسمح كل انواع
التحفيز في تصنيع مجموعات مسلحه ان يبدو
على الناس ما يحصل كذلك تقول فقره السلطه
على مواطنيها مواطنيها الغاضرين جدا بسبب
تهديد منازلهم بهذه الطريقه التي تزايدت
بشكل كبير هذه الاعتداءات من جانب
المستوطنين وهذه التصريحات المستفزه من
جانب بنفير الذي يبدو انه لم يسمع ما
الشرطه اليه من تقييد اليد او لم يطابقه
على الاقل
ما حصلت خوار ابو المريع وان رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل ورئيس اسرائيل ادانا هذا
ذلك الذي تكرر ولكن لكن هذه اجراءات رادعه
يتخذونها قبل سنه كانت هناك دراسه قامت
بها
الذين فشلوا في العمليات الانتحار الذاتي
هو وجدوا ان هؤلاء الذين ينتحروا يفجر
انفسهم لانها عندك قالوا بانه كان يعرفون
ان اساهم ستتعرض للاذى قاموا بمثل هذا
العمل وبالتالي فان التدوير الاسئله امر
مهم للتاكد من القواعد لا تسمح لي
عليه الاسود وغيرها من الجماعات اصبح اكبر
اليوم وبعد تدمير المنازل وسيبقى هذا
موضوع نناقشه
شكرا لك من كبير المرسلين السياسيين في
صحيفه الجلوس في الواقع سنناقش هذا
الموضوع ايضا مع ضيفنا من رام الله دكتور
مصطفى البرهوتي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اهلا بك مصطفى اذا
لنبدا من تصريح رئيس الاركان الحديث عن
ثمن بعض جراء التصعيد تكبدته اسرائيل ماذا
تقرا في هذا التصريح
اقرا امرين اولا ان اسرائيل
اثبتت مره اخرى انها لا تفهم الى لغه
القوه وانا لديها حساسيه شديده لثلاث
انواع من الخسائر حساسيه شديده للخسائر
البشريه
ولذلك كل عمليه تقع يعني تسبب
هزه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي وثانيا ان
لديها حساسيه شديده للخسائر الاقتصاديه
وطبعا هناك تدهور اقتصادي الان في اسرائيل
وثالثا انا لديهم حساسيه من خسائر
الاخلاقيه والمعنويه وما جرى في حواره
يعني كشف وعره بشكل كامل طبيعه هذه
المنظومه الارهابيه التي اسمها اسرائيل
وبالمناسبه المستوطنون لم يقوموا بالاعمال
والاجرام والارهاب الذي قاموا به الا
بحمايه الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي ساعدهم
وحماهم ورقب كيف قاموا بحرق بيوت
الفلسطينيين وسياراتهم ومركباتهم وفي هذه
اللحظه تجري عمليات ارهابيه جديده
اسرائيليه سواء في حواره او في منطقه جبل
صبيح في بيتها وانا احيي الشباب الفلسطيني
واهالي وشعبنا الفلسطيني الباسل الذي
يتلاحم الان مع بعضه البعض
ويتصدى لهؤلاء المستعمرين المستوطنين بكل
قوه وبكل بطوله اسرائيل تكرر باستمرار نفس
الروايه لا تفهم الى لغه القوه وما يتعرض
له الشعب الفلسطيني يقررنا الان من صوره
مشابهه لمجاره عام 48 عصابات صهيونيه في
حينه ارتكبت المجازر مثل مجزره دير ياسين
واليوم عصابات صهيونيه اخرى
مستعملين مستوطنين بحمايه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقوموا بكل هذا الاجرام ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني والعالم كله يراقب ولكن
العالم ايضا يشجب اليوم يعني سمع
المقاربهم قبل مسؤولين عده
وان كانت لغه الاعلام ربما ولغه حتى
الجامعات في الغرب اقوى بكثير من لغه
الحكومات ولكن الا تلعب دورا هنا في
ممارسه نوع من الضغط ام يعني ليس بالحجم
الكافي
اخت ليلى نحن نتابع الان استراتيجيه وطنيه
كفاحيه المقاومه
وانا برايي الشيء الوحيد الذي سيرضع
اسرائيل هي المقاومه اجرامها على الارض
والحمله العالميه الواسعه على الصعيد
الشعبي لفضل المقاطعه والعقوبات عليها
وهذه حمله ستتصاعد اكثر كلما انكشفت
اسرائيل وطابع الارهابي ما تقوم به لكن من
ناحيه اخرى انا اعتقد ان الموقف الامريكي
منافق يعني يقولوا يجب ان يحاسب المجرمين
طب لماذا لم يتابعوا محاسبه الذين قتلوا
شيرين ابو عاقله مع انهم طلبوا بلجنه
تحقيق مستقله ودارت اسرائيل ظهرها لهم
يقولوا انه مع حل الدولتين ويقول ان
الاستيطاني يدمر هذه الدولتين لماذا يسكت
على اسرائيل ان كان هناك دوله في العالم
تستطيع ان تنجم التوسع الاستيطاني هي
الولايات المتحده هل تحدد اسرائيل بعقوبات
لا طبعا يراقب ما يجري ويسمع سعر مستعمله
جديده حصل عفوا
الشاشه بيحصل وايضا بكثير يقول انها
سننتقل الى مرحله هجوم يعني يصاعد بمعنى
اخر
الى اين يسير البشر
الى مواجهه طبعا لانه الشعب الفلسطيني لا
يستطيع ان يقف مكتوف الايدي ويراقب ارضه
تسرق واولاده وابنائه وبناته يهددون
وحياتهم تهدد
والاعتداءات جاريه في كل مكان انا اسرائيل
تجور المنطقه الانفجار شامل ولا يملك
الشعب الفلسطيني الا ان يدافع عن نفسه
ولكن نحن ايضا يجب ان نضع العالم امام
مسؤولياته ويجب ان يقال للعالم ان اردتم
وقف الاستيطان فلتفرضوا عقوبات على
اسرائيل اما ان تواصلوا الحديث بالكلام
المنافق وتتستر بكلمه حل الدولتين للتنصل
والمسؤولياتكم فهذا امر لا يمكن ان يقبل
به الشعب الفلسطيني على كل حال انا برايي
اتحول العالمي سيحدث على مستوى الشعوب
وستفرض الشعوب ضغوطاتها على الحكومات نحن
نعيش نفس السيناريو الذي عاشته جنوب
افريقيا في نضارها ضد عبر تمييز العنصري
ولكن في هذه الحاله نحن ننظم ليس فقط
ضد الاحتلال الاطول في التاريخ الحديث وضد
اسوا منظومه تمييز عنصري في تاريخ البشريه
الامن العام للمبادره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى اوكرانيا الان قالت وزاره الدفاع هناك
الى وحداتها استهدفت عناصر في محيط مدينه
بخويت وانها تذكرت من قتل العديد منهم
بينما انتهت الجبهه الشماليه لباخ
التهبت بشكل لافت واقر قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه لان الوضع في محيط المدينه
متوترا للغايه مضيفا انا ميليشيات تستخدم
وحداتها الاكثر استعدادا لاختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه ومحاصات المدينه
ماذا بقي من محمود ومن بقي فيها سته اشهر
والمدينه توتوكو قصفا واستهدافا وضحت محطه
رهان روسيا والاوكرانيين فهي رمز للصمود
الجيش كما سبق ان قال الرئيس الاوكراني
زينسكي
الاكبر بعد ان جفت خزائنهم من تحقيق
اختراق بارز على الجبهات يتحدث قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه عن استخدام
وحالتها الاكثر استعدادا لاختراق دفاعات
الاوكرانيه ومحاصره المدينه
اتصاعد في الايام الاخيره جعل المحور
الشماليه من بخموت اخطر المحاور واكثر
الجبهه سخونه رغم ان الهجوم على ضخمه يتم
من الشمال والشرق وحتى الجنوب مراسل
الجزيره افادا بتمكن القوات الروسيه من
احدث ما يشبه اللسان بتقدمها بين قريتين
الاولى هي
وتبعد نحو سته كيلومترات ونصف عن وسط
والقريه الثانيه هي قريه وتبعد نحو
عن وسط مدينه وهذا الامر منح القوه
الروسيه فرصه لتكون اقرب الى الطريق
الوحيد المستخدم في هذه المناطق وهو طريق
الالتفافي تقول روسيا ان جميع طرق من والى
بخموت اصبحت تحت السيطره ناريه لقوتها
فاعلم ماذا تبحث
السيطره على مخلوط تعد اطول المعارك التي
خذتها روسيا خلال حربها على اوكرانيا حيث
تحاول منذ اكثر من سته اشهر احدث اختراق
فيها وتحقيق ذلك
خطوط الامداد الاوكرانيه في الشرق ولكن
العين بالاساس على الصبيان
فرصه لتقدم قوتها والوصول الى اهم معاقل
القوه الاوكرانيه
وهذا الاختراق وسيعني ان القوه الروسيه
ستطرق بشكل شبه كامل على منطقه بعد ان ظلت
ممسكه بزمام المبادره والسيطره فيما يجعل
اقليم دومباس بشكل كامل تحت سيطرتها
يتهم الاوكرانيون باستخدام ما يسمونه
تكتيك تدمير الكامل والارهاب بينما يتحدث
مؤسس عن معلومه استخباراتيه تؤكد بدء وصول
الطلائع الاولى لدبابات الى القوات
الاوكرانيه قد يكون ذلك مؤشرا على ان
الحسم لن يكون سهلا للروس او بلا ثمن لدعم
غربي للكياف
جزء من سوره المشهد اجمالا استعدادات
لرابيع ساخن
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
حسب الاشياء بعد نعرف انها تطوق باختي
قريبه جدا وتستعمل افضل سلاح لديها
لاختراق القوات الاوكرانيه
كم هي قريبه في الواقع على الارض لكي تضع
يدها على نفسها
لا لا الهدف الاساسي وهناك
البحريه الروسيه تقاتل في نفس الوقت الهدف
الاساسي هو التطبيق ولكن هذا التطبيق لا
يزال منذ سته اشهر التطبيق يعني قطع خطوط
المواصلات بالاتجاه الغربي التطبيق يعني
تدمير المدينه ولكن هنا يبقى السؤال هل
سيبقى الجيش الاوكراني مع النخب الاساسيه
داخل مخموض ام سيكون هناك انسحاب تكتيكي
الى منطقه تكون غرب على سبيل المثال حيث
يصل اليها طلائع الدبابات التي اعطتها
بولندا نحن امام مرحله مفصليه ولكن هذا
الحديث يعني منذ فتره اشهر نقول مخمود هل
سيضحي الجيش الاوكراني بنخبه جيشه في
مخموض ام سينسحب على غرار ما حصل في
الانسحاب التكتيكي
الجهد لحفظ بعض القوات بانتظار المرحله
القادمه او التحضير الهجوم مرتقب وصول
الدبابات هنا هل سيحسم الامر سواء باتجاه
المواجهه او الانسحاب التكتيكي الذي اشد
اليه
هو لا لن يحكم الامر الدبابات يعني
الدبابات يجب ان تكون ليله من ضمن منظومه
قتال مشترك للاسلحه المدفعيه الدبابات
المشاه والطيران والصواريخ والحمايه
الجويه هذه منظومه ولكن قدوم الدبابات هذا
مؤشر تكتيكي بسيط يكون قد تكون
او المرحله او المنطقه ما وراء او غير
مخموض هي منطقه الدفاع الخط الثاني وكان
ممول
بعد بريكوجين قال انه كل ما تقدمنا عشره
امتار هناك قلعه محصنه وكل بيت قلعه محصنه
وحتى اذا اردنا ان نحتل او نسترجع او
نسترد اقليم قد يستغرق الامر سنتين يعني
محمود سته اشهر ماذا عن الصبيانس ماذا عن
كرامات وهي مدن تعتبر تقريبا كبيره وضحت
الفكره شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
شركه الاقمار الاصطناعيه الصينيه
وفرت صوره اقمار صناعيه من اوكرانيا لدعم
ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه في عملياتها
القتاليه التي تنفذها لصالح
وبعد ايام فقط على الذكرى السنويه الاولى
لبدء الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا عرض وزير
الخارجيه
الامريكيتيه السابقه الخمس في اسيا الوسطى
لتقليص اعتمادها على روسيا محذرا من اي
تقلب في المواقف ازاء ملف اوكرانيا قد
التقى بلينك في استانا ووزراء خارجيه
كازاخستان
طاجكستان وتركمانستان واكد لهم دعم واشنطن
لبلدانهم والاستقلالها
في اسيا الوسطى مع عقيل النفوذ الروسي
المثقل بالتاريخ والجغرافيا تدشن الولايات
المتحده جبهه التنافس جديده مع موسكو وعلى
نحو اقل مع بيجين مركز الهزه الدبلوماسيه
كان استان عاصمه كازاخستان التي زرعها
وزير الخارجيه
لكن الارتدادات مرتقبه والمرجوه امريكيا
تشمل الى جانب كازاخستان 4 جمهوريات
سوفيات اخرى هي اوزباكستان
وقرقيزيستان وتاجكستان
وتركمانستان في استناء
من الدول الخمس واكد لهم دعم بلاده
لجمهورياتهم في تعزيز سيادتها ووحده
اراضيها واستقلالها وقد بدات كازاخستان
معنيه اكثر من غيرها بحديث بلينكل
فالجمهوريه المتراميه الاطراف تتشارك مع
روسيا حدودا بدون 7000
وخمسمائه كيلومتر وفيها اقليه روسيه كبيره
العدد
رغم نسجها تحالفات خارجيه مختلفه ظل نفوذ
موسكو فيها ساحقا الى حد ارسال العمل
الماضي قوات اليها لمساعدتها في قمع
مظاهرات ضد السلطه
وهو ارفع مسؤولين امريكي يزور اسيا الوسطى
منذ تسلم اداره بايدن السلطه جاء حاملا
الوعود والعروض لتلك العواصم التي ظلت رغم
تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي في فلك موسكو
اختيارا حينا واضطرارا في احيان كثيره
بسبب الجغرافيا والشراكات الامنيه
والاقتصاديه فهل تنجح واشنطن في الدخول
على خط الحضور الروسي القوي واغراءات
الصين الجذابه
الوزير الامريكي الذي انتقل الى
اوزباكستان بعد كازاخستان لا يبدو في مهمه
سهله غير ان اللحظه التاريخيه قد تكون
مؤاتيه اكثر من اي وقت اخر فموسكو مشغوله
بحربها على اوكرانيا وهذه الدول تزداد
هواجسها من تداعيات تلك الحرب عليها
اهلا وسهلا
اذن هذا التحرك الامريكي في الفضاء
السوفياتي السابق دول ما زالت تحتفظ روسيا
كيف تقراه وكيف تقرا فرص نجاحه
الهدف الرئيسي بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
في هذه الحرب الوكاله ضد روسيا هي بالوضوح
بشكل واضح هي عزل واضعاف روسيا
وكان هذا اكبر اخفاق للنيتو لحد الان
وطبعا جائزه الكبرى الولايات المتحده
ان تبعد بعض حلفاء روسيا التقديم في اسيا
الوسطى
وبالذات سيكون امر مهمه للولايات المتحده
ولكن على الارجاح الامر للنجاح الى حد
كبير لانه في هذه المنطقه اهم الشريكين
هما روسيا والصين ولكن طبعا
الولايات المتحده ايضا
التجاره ولكن اعتقد توقعات الامريكيه
قد تجاوز لحد كبير ما هو معقول
صينيه خصوص
ا
تراقب ما يجري الان
في هل نتوقع تحرك ما بهذا الاتجاه
وفي الواقع لو الولايه ان الولايات تنجح
فقد يفعل شيئا ولكنني اعتقد
انه ليس هناك توقعات كبيره لما يمكن ان
يحققه امريكا وطبعا ان الصيد تواجه خطرا
بالنسبه لروسيا ولايه المتحده تستخدم
الناتو للتاثير على روسيا وفي اسيا ايضا
الذي تحدث ان تهاجم صله باستخدام التايوان
وحلفاء اخرون في شرق اسيا ولكن اسيا
الوسطى هي منطقه مهمه قد تثير مشاكل
الولايات المتحده لاشراكه الكبيره بين
روسيا والصين هي واحد من الخوف امريكا
الرئيسيه حصلت مشاكل في اسيا الوسطى
المهمه ومفيدا
شكرا جزيلا لك من اصل
استاذه العلاقه الدوليه شكرا جزي
لا التغيير والعقيده العسكريه اليابان
نهايه العام الماضي في ظل تحولات وتغييرات
جذريه في البيئه الجيوسيه المحيطه بها
العقيده التي اعتمدتها الحرب العالميه
الثانيه شهدت تغييرا جذريا لناحيه حجم
الانفاق العسكري والمشاركه في عمليات
عسكريه خارجيه وهو ما ينظر اليه كمؤشر
بارز في سياق التوتر السنين الامريكيه
متصاعد في المنطقه وفي سلسله تقارير خاصه
بملف التوتر في شرق اسيا نسلط الضوء في
التقرير التاليه على تحديات التي تواجهها
العقيده العسكريه اليابانيه الجديده
في هذه الجزيره النائيه تتشكل ملامح عقيده
عسكريه جديده لليابان
توترات المنطقه تنعكس بوضوح هنا
فجزيره يونا جوني تبعد 110 كم فقط عن
تايوان المنطقه
المتصاعد بين الصين والولايات المتحده
قياده اليابانيه عام 2019
لجعل ينادوني المعروفه بطبيعتها المسالمه
بعقود قاعده متقدمه لغداره عسكريه ترصد
تحركات البحريه الصينيه
هذه سلسله جزر الجنوب اليابانيه وهي تشكل
دائما جدارا يعرقل طموح الصيني بتوسيع
نفوذها والتمدد نحو المحيط الهادئ وهناك
ستكون الساحه المواجهه ولن يكون تورط
الياباني بتلك المواجهه سوى مساله وقت فقط
ولذلك علينا الاسراع بتعزيز دفاعتنا على
الجزر الجنوبيه
من بوابه القصر الامبراطوري
في تاريخ اليابانيين
في معركه شهيره لحمايه العرش اليوم وبعد
700 عاما على تلك الحادثه تستحضر وزاره
الدفاع اليابانيه
مثالي وضع صورته على تقرير العقيده
العسكريه الجديده
قبل هذا التقرير الجديد للعقيده العسكريه
كانت هناك محطات تاريخيه مهمه لتوقف عندها
فبعد هزيمتها في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وقعت اليابان تحت الاحتلال الامريكي سبع
سنوات حتى عام 1952
وبعد الاستقرار صيغه ما تعرف بوفائط
استراتيجيه الامن القومي التي تعتبر دليل
الارشاديه للقوانين المتعلقه بامن اليابان
والدفاع عن اراضيها
منذ اقراها لاول مره عام
شهدت العقيده العسكريه اليابانيه تغييرات
عده
بدايه التصاد دور القوات اليابانيه على
الدفاع ضمن حدود اليمن بقيت كذلك حتى عام
2013 حين سمح للقوات اليابانيه بالقتال
خارج الحدود ضمن حق دفاع الجماعي
فقط شهدته العقيده العسكريه نهايه عن
الماضي سمحت القوات اليابانيه بشن هجمات
مضاده وارتفاع عن حلفائها حتى لو لم تواجه
تهديدا مباشرا
تحديات الامنيه المتزايده بفعل الاخرين
متناثر على طول 3000 كيلومترن والنزاعات
الحدوديه مع الجيران بسببه فرضت على
اليابان توسيع قوتها العسكريه
لكن ذلك كان يعني بساط ضيق بين قيود دستور
وتهديدات الامن القومي
فالماده التاسعه من الدستور تمنع الاختراق
في اي نزاع خارج الحدود
وتعديلها يتطلب استفتاء وطنيا
[موسيقى]
بموجب التعديل الجديد تقفز اليران من
المرتبه التاسعه من حيث الانفاق العسكري
الى الثالثه بعد الولايات المتحده والصين
استراتيجيه الدفاع الجديده ليس فقط
برنامجا لتطوير العسكري بالخطه الشامله
لكن هناك تساؤلات كبيره حول قدره رئيس
الوزراء على انجاح تلك الخطط التي تواجه
مشكلتين تتمثلان بتامين مصادر التمويل
والقوه البشريه واذا لم تنجح خطته فقد
يكون مستقبل سياسي على المحكمه
منذ عام 2014 لم تحقق وزاره الدفاع
اليابانيه وهدفها من اعداد مجندين
في العام الماضي اسباب عديده وراء ذلك
منها منافسه القطاع الخاص الذي يوفر رواتب
عاليه للشباب المتعلم
بطاله منخفض ومن المتوقع ان يزداد نقص
المجندين بسبب ارتفاع متوسط
عقارات اخرى تواجه تطبيق الاستراتيجيه
الدفاعيه الجديده وهي توفير 320 مليار
دولار خلال خمس سنوات لتغطيه تكاليف خطط
تعزيز القوه العسكريه بينما تعاني اليابان
من اكبر دين عام بين الدول الصناعيه
الكبرى فرئيس الوزراء
لم يكشف مصدر تمويل اضافي مكتفيا بالتعهد
بعدم زياده الضرائب على الدخل او اصدار
سندات خزينه
[موسيقى]
يستعرض هذا الاسطول الياباني قدراته
بالتزامن مع اعلان الحكومه
استراتيجيتها الجديده للامن القومي
استراتيجيه تعلن بها دخول اليابان نادي
القوه العسكريه الغربيه ليس كمراقب كما
كان الحال طوال عقود ملك شريكا قويا يكون
حره للغرب في شرق اسيا
فاليسا الجزيره طوكيو
معنا الان العقيده الكسندر رئيس تحرير
المجله العسكريه السويسريه اهلا وسهلا بك
اذا اليابان تدخل نادي القوه العسكريه
الغربيه من اوسع ابوابه
هل سنشهد عوده الروح القتاليه في اليابان
روح السماوي
ة اذا كنا نتحدث عن الساموراي في القرنين
السادس عشر والسابع عشر اعتقد بعيدون عن
ذلك وهو منطق المحارب الفرد لان اليابان
تتطلع قدما الى احياء قواتها العسكريه
والتحديثها خاصه فيما يتعلق بالدفاعات
الجويه بسبب خطر الصواريخ ذاتيه الدفع
وتريد ان تستعرض قواها بشكل جماعي
وبالتعاون اذا نحن بعيدون جدا عن رمزيه
الساموراي الان ولكن اليس صحيح ا الشعب
الياباني الذي لعقود بعيدا تماما عن موضوع
الحروب وبعيدا عن الانفاق الا في مجال
الاقتصاد وبناء الدوله الان
الحكومه تقول له تغيرت الامور
سننسى عقد
عقد كوريا الجنوبيه لا نسال هناك ايضا
عقده بهذا الموضوع تجاه كوريا وما فعلت
اليابان في السابق الشباب الان في حل من
هذه العقده الى اي حد
سيؤثر هذا على الموقف الحكومي هل سيتجاوز
عتبه المجتمع
افتقد ان ذكريات الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ما تزال ما صله في اذهان الراي العام
للشعب والحكومه لكن كما قلت
على صواب في ذلك ان هناك امور تغيرت
فيما
يتعلقوهات التهديد التي تحيط باليابان
اولا الانصاق الكبير فيما يتعلق باعاده
الصين تصليح نفسها ثانيا المتحده الان
بعيده ومنشغله بشؤونها في اوروبا وقد لا
تكون قادره على حمايه اليابان وثالثا كما
قلت اليابان لم تعد جزيره في الان يمكن ان
تستهدف من بعد الاف الكيلومترات عن طريق
الصواريخ كيف تقدر اهم التحديات التي تقف
امام العقيده العسكريه الجديده اليابان
اليابان عليها الان ان تواجهها تهديدات
الصواريخ
البالسيه والصواريخ كروزه وربما الروس
النوويه ولا تمتلك حلا سحريا عدا طبعا
التعاون العسكري مع الحلفاء في المحيط
الهادئ وايضا
انطلاق انظمه دفاع جويه يتم بناءها
بالتعاونه المتحده
وثالثا اليابان ستحتاج الى ان تستعرض
قوتها بحيث تقترب من مصادر تهديد التي قد
تاتي التهديدات منها العقيد الكسندر الفطر
في الرئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
والخلافات في التجاره والملف الملكيه
الفكريه
مواجهه جديده بين الصين والولايات المتحده
ساحتها اليوم التكنولوجيا اذ امهر البيت
الابيض الفيدراليه 30 يوما لكي تحضر تطبيق
تيك توك الصينيه على هواتفها واجهزتها كما
تتجه الى الغاء تراخيص مرحت لشركات
الامريكيه لتصدير معدات الى شركه هواوي
الصينيه
تيك توك ممنوع في اجهزه الوكالات الرسميه
في الولايات المتحده فالتطبيق الذي تملكه
شركه صينيه قد يشكل خطرا على الامن القومي
الامريكي هذه السندجه سبق لوكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه المتوسط اليها
وحذفت من ان المخابرات الصينيه يمكن ان
تعترض بيانات مستخدمين تيك توك
عام 2020 فهل يمكن الاستيقانون ان تجمع
بيانات المستخدمين
استفت مرارا تعويضها ان مستخبي تطبيق لاي
خطر لكن ما يعزز المخاوف الامريكيه
والغربيه وجود قانون صيني دخل حادثه
التنفيذ عام 2016
ويفرض القانون تحت مسمى مكافحه الارهاب
على الشركات الانترنت العامه في الصين
تسليم مفاتيح التشفير وكلمات المرور
للحكومه الصينيه عند الطلب اضافه لقانون
دخل حديث عام 2017
ويتيح رقبه على البيانات وتخزينها في
الشركات العامله في البلاد وبناء عليه
تحطم التقارير امنيه امريكيه من انهم
مطريا يمكن للصين استخدام البيانات للتجسس
على المستخدمين الافراد ومراقبه نشاطهم
واستهدافهم مباشره بحمالات التضليل كما
يمكن بحسب المخاوف الامريكيه ان تستخدم
بنزين البيانات لمهاجمه الولايات المتحده
بحملات لزعزعه استقرار الحكومه الامريكيه
واذا كانت الحال مع تيك توك تتعلق بجمع
البيانات لما تحدث التعامل مع تقنيات قبل
نحو عام صنفت هيئه الاتصالات الفيدراليه
في الولايات المتحده شركه هواوي من ضمن
شركات معدات الاتصالات الصينيه التي تشكل
تهديدا للامن وتهديد الامي في اعتبار
السياسيين امريكيين شركه هواوي بمثابه
ذراع تجاريه للحزب الشيوعي الصيني اضافه
الاتهامات توجه للشركه بتنفيذ عمليات سرقه
ملكيه فكريه وامكانيه استخدام تقنيه الجيل
الخامس في التجسس وهي تقنيه
في نقل البيانات
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء نقلت
التجاره الامريكيه جنرماندو قولها ان
الولايات المتحده تشتري اكثر من 90% من
الرقائق الالكترونيه المتقدمه من تايوان
وهي ثغره امن قومي لا يمكن الدفاع عنها
واضافت ريموندو ان كل قطعه من المعدات
العسكريه المتطوره وكل طائره دون طيار وكل
قمر اصطناعي يعتمد على هذه الرقائق كما
نقلت الصحيفه عن وثيقه امريكيه تتعلق
بسياسات اداره بايدن حول الرقائق الجيش
الامريكي غير قادر حاليا على الحصول على
رقائق متطوره من مصدر داخلي وهو ما يجعل
الانظمه العسكريه الحساسه عرضه لاضطراب
الامداد
مخاطر الادويه
اهلا وسهلا بك يعني في الواقع هناك
شقان نريد ان نتحدث عنهما الشق الاول
يتعلق
والاخر يتعلق بالرقائق الالكترونيه لنبدا
بموضوع تيك توك الذي يثور حوله جدل كبير
وليس بالجديد
الخطوه الان التي اتخذت هل هذا يعني ان
هناك دليل
تستند اليه واشنطن وغير مدونه ان هناك
فعلا خطر على الامن القومي ان هناك ثبت
التجسس هنا
حكومه لا تتحد لا تقول ان هناك تجسس لكن
هناك مخاوف من ان اي شركه صينيه بامكانها
ان
تاخذ بيانات
وتوصلها الى الحكومه الصينيه
وهناك مخاوف الكثير من البيانات المتاحه
وبحيث
يؤدي الى احتمال ان تكون هناك
معلومات عن
التوجهات
السكانيه
وغيرها والحكومه الامريكيه لا تريد
الحكومه الصينيه ان تحصل على هذه البيانات
وهذا بهذا المعنى حتى لو كانت المصادر
مفتوحه مرتاحه قد تكون استقباليه ولكن
اليس صحيحه ان هذا الامر ينطبق على كثير
من التطبيقات
بما فيها تطبيقات امريكيه فتح الباب بهذه
الطريقه لمنع تطبيق بناء على مخاوف فقط
الا يجعلنا عرضه
لربما موجه جديده تحول من نوع اخر في
العالم الرقمي الالكتروني
واقع الحال عندما يكون هناك تطبيق للتواصل
الاجتماعي مثل تيك توك تستعمل على نطاق
واسع والبيانات قد توصل الى كانت حكوميه
هنا موقف حقيقي مؤكد يتجاوز عن استخدام
التجاري او التعائي للبيانات
لان هذا
يجعل ان هذا الحجم من البيانات حول
الافراد ان تؤخذ ثم تسلم الى حكومه في بلد
اخر يتم
تمحيصها وتحليلها
لتخرج باخلاصات وتستهدف الناس هذه حقيقه
الموقف بان تطبيقا تجاريا يجد طريقه
وبياناته الى ايدي حكومه طبعا هذا الوقت
اذا سمحت بالنسبه للرقائق الالك ترونيه
وايضا قضيه ان الدوله في الولايات المتحده
تعتمد على مصدر واحد 90% من الرقائق
الالكترونيه تاتي من تايوان وهذا في حد
يعني عام استفهام كبرى ويدعو ايضا
ان الموقف الذي
ستسار الكثير من الامريكي لماذا وضعنا
انفسنا في هذا الموقف اصلا نحن في
امريكيين في البدايه كنا ننتج هذه
المنتجات لكن اصبح مجديا اقتصاديا اكثر ان
نستوردها وهذا في النهايه اصبح مصدر ضغط
قد يستخدموا ضدنا من حيث التنافسيه لذا
هناك حركه واسعه
لاعاده مثل هذه الصناعات اذا لا المتحده
او الى اماكن اقل تهديدا
شكرا جزيلا لك جودي
مدير الانترنت
اذا هذا القلق الامريكي بشان انتاج او
استيراد الرقائق الالكترونيه يعيد تسطيط
الضوء على تلك الرقائق التي تعرف باشباه
الموصلات ودخولها في كل الصناعات الحديثه
تقريبا
اشباه المؤثرات هي تلك رقائق السوداء التي
تصنع من السيليكون لتتحكم في مرور التيار
الكهربائي ولا يعمل اي جهاز الكتروني من
دونها الرقائق دقيقه الحجم تدخل في كثير
من الصناعات الالكترونيه الهواتف الذكيه
والحواسيب والسيارات والطائرات والشبكات
المعلوماتيه وصولا لاجهزه العدديه ويبلغ
حجم سوق دقائق العالميه نحو 430 مليار
دولار الصين تستهلك نحو 60% من الانتاج
العالمي لاشباه موصله بينما تهيمن
التايوان على نحو 60% من اجمالي تصنيع
العالمي لتلك الرقائق وتعتبر الشركه
تايوان لتصنيع اشباه الموصلات الكبرى
عالميا بقيمه سوقيه تتجاوز 600 مليار
دولار
الولايات المتحده تستورد
90% من استهلاكها من تلك الرقائق ما يعد
وفق وزيره التجاره الامريكيه ثغره امنيه
تلك المخاوف الامريكيه دفعت واشنطن لتخصيص
52 مليار دولار بدعم قطاع الرقائق
الالكترونيه على اراضيها كما انها اوقفت
تصدير رقائق الاشباح الموصلات الى الصين
كجزء من حرب التكنولوجيه تشمها على الجيل
[موسيقى]
اي مستقبل ترسمه فرنسا لوجودها العسكري في
افريقيا هذا السؤال يثيره حديث الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون عن نموذج شراكه
جديد
في القاره سواء بانسحاب القوات الفرنسيه
او التزايد حضور روسيا
ومما تنص عليه سياسه باريس الجديده تجاه
افريقيا خفض عدد قواتها هنا والاستعاذه عن
القواعد العسكريه المنتظمه باقامه
اكاديميات للتدريب والتجهيز تشترك في
ادانتها الجيش المحليه ياتي هذا التوجه
وستراجع نفوذ فرنسا بشكل ملموس في
مستعمراتها السابقه على وقع انقلابات هزت
دولا في غرب افريقيا في العامين الماضيين
وتقاطعت خيارات نخبها العسكريه مع مظاهرات
شعبيه تطالب بالحد من النفود الفرنسي
تراجع ذلك النفوذ بشكل لافت مع هذا حصل مع
مغادرتي اخر جندي من قوات عمليه ادخال
الاراضي المائيه في صيف العام الماضي عفوا
الاراضي الماليه طبعا هذا حصل بعد ازمه
غير مسبوقه مع المجلس العسكري في
وفي مقابل تناقص مساحه النفود الفرنسيه
التقليدي كان الفلسطيني يتنامى في القاره
السمراء وذلك من بوابه الاقتصاد اذ اصبحت
الشركه الاقتصاديه الاكبر لافريقيا
فاصبحت في ظرف وجيز ايضا اكبر مصدر سلاح
للقاره بالاضافه الى توفيرها
عبر شركات امنيه
تشعر باريس بالقلق من تنامي التنافس
الدوري في نقاط تعتبرها حيويه في افريقيا
مع مزيد من الدول الافريقيه
من اسباب ذلك ما يوصف في افريقيا بالهيمنه
الفرنسيه على الموارد الاقتصاديه كذلك
التاثير في تشكيل الواقع السياسي في الدول
الغرب والوسط
من الاسباب ايضا الفشل في التصدي لمخاطر
الانتشار الجماعات المتطرفه في دول الساحل
والصحراء وذلك عبر عمليه رخان التي بدات
في عام 2014
بهذه الانعطاف في العلاقات الفرنسيه
الافريقيه توجه كثير من الافارقه نحو
شراكات جديده بدت لهم اكثر نادية وانصافا
ومراعاه لمصالحه
اذا سنناقش كل هذه النقاط
اوتو مدير معهد
الافريقي والدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد اوتو اذا لنبدا من تصريح
الرئيس الفرنسي الذي بدا يعني الى حد ما
يحمل نبره تصالحيه
ما يمكن ان نراه من بيان الرئيسي الفرنسيه
تصريحه هو مؤشر واضح على ان فرنسا
تتطلعوا الى تغيير جذري
في احتكارها الجيره السياسيه لمنطقه
الساحل
وافريقيا فهي الان ترى نفسها في خضار
متنافس شديد في هذه اللحظه الزمنيه بحيث
لم تعد تمتلك ادوات الضغط العسكريه التي
كانت تمتلكها في القاره الافريقيه ولا ذلك
التاثير السياسي الشيء الوحيد الذي بقي
لها وهو
البوابه التعاون والتجاره الاخيره هي
تاثيرها من حيث اللغه الفرنسيه في بلدان
الساحل وهذا البلدان ما تزال تستخدمه بعض
العمل
فرنسا طبعا في هذا محاوله لاحيائي نفوذها
لكن اعتقد ان الوقت قد فات للرئيس الفرنسي
ماذا عن الدول الافريقيه هل تنسى ربما
مواقف عديده اعتبرتها احتكار تعدي اساءه
هل تعتقد ان هذا الامر سيلقى تجاوبا
الافريقيه بقى الماضيه قدما في حياتها
متجاوزه
المرحله التي سبقت الاستعمار ومرحله ما
بعد الاستعمار خاصه
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
لم يعد لديهم اي تاثير في ذلك الجزء من
القاره الافريقيه
فقد تم طردهم من شعوب افريقيا الوسطى
والذين باتوا يقيمون علاقات معروس اكثر
ايضا بلدان سليماني بوركينا فاسو كما ترون
العمليات
الفرنسيه هذه كلها تم ابعاد فرنسا منها
وقالت هذه البلدان بصوت واضح انها تريد
ممارسه استقلالها هذا ما اسميه مرحله
استقلال جديده
واستقلال حقيقي لهذه البلدان لانما حدث في
رغم ان هذه البلدان حصلت على استقلال
فرنسا لكن بقي هناك
السيطره وحضور عسكري وحضور نظري ولكن
حقيقي فيها ممارسه
وعدم قدره لممارسات عقيده السياده الوطنيه
هذا البلدان تمضي قدما الى الامام الان
وترى في فرنسا امرا من الماضي وما نراه
الاعلى ان الفلسطينيه
ما يسمح بهذا الوقت حتى الان شكرا جزيلا
لك للامن
اذا قرار الراس الساعه
ثواني واليكم الان تذكيرا
اشهد
يثير مزيدا من ردود الفعل رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي يقول ان هجمات المستوطنين جبلت
اسرائيل فمن باهضا ويتعهد لتحقيق فيها
والجيش يغلق مداخل مدن لملاحقه منافذ
عمليات حواره واريحا ويكشف عن مناورات
الاحد في الضفه وفي مقابله يقول ان الوضع
كارثي ويؤكد ضروره الالتزام بتفاهمات
العقبه
بخمت على ابواب الحسم بعد تاكيد قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه صعوبه تطبيق
المدينه ليش تتحدث عن تقدم شماليه المدينه
الاستراتيجيه وقوه مواليه لروسيا تقول
ان كل الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه باتت في
مرمى نيرانها
مسؤولون امريكيون يتهمون شركه صينيه بدعم
ميليشيا بصور اقمار اصطناعيه وفي تمددا
لمساحه التنفس الروسي الامريكي يتحرك في
الفضاء السوفيتي السابق ويلتقي مسؤوليه
خمس دول في السنه ويطالب بموقف واضح من
العقوبه على روسيا في اذربيجان قبل التوجه
الاجتماعي مجموعه العشرين
ينتقل الى التكنولوجيا تيك توك وهواوي في
مرمى اتهامات متبادله بين واشنطن البيت
الابيض يحضر استخدام التطبيق الصيني على
الموظفين الفيدراليين بسبب مخاوف امنيه
وتتجه لتقييد تصدير معدات لشركه هواوي
تتهمها بتوظيف مفهوم الامن القومي في مجال
التنافس التجاري
[موسيقى]
وفي حوار خاص مع الجزيره اكد منسق
للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي
تشجب العنف في الاراضي الفلسفيه
بالطبع نحن
نشكر كل انواع العنف وهذا غير مقبول سمعتم
الشركاء
الاسرائيلين الرئيس هيتسوق ورئيس الوزاره
الاستديو يقولون انه من غير مقبول ان يقوم
المواطن العادي باخذ انفاذ القانون بيده
نحن لا نريد رؤيه اي شكل من اشكال النفره
نريد لاي احد يتضرر ما نزال نرى
حلت دولتين ناجع ونريدها
النشاط الاستيطاني ان يتوقف ويكون الحل
على اساس حل الدولتين
انا الولايات المتحده تعتبر المستوطنات
عقبه امام السلام وقبل الرئيس بايدن يعتقد
ان حل الدولتين هو طريق التوصيل للسلام
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيلي
كان واضحا تماما حول ابتسامنا بحل الدوله
وقد حاجز بهذا القول ليس فقط الخاصه
ايضا الوزير بلينكيز ايضا ابقى على هذه
العمليه مستمره على الصعيد الدبلوماسي
المتحده تستمر
في دعمها لحل الدوله التاليه نعتقد ان هذا
هو السبيل الامثل ليس فقط الفلسطينيه
والاسرائيليه للمنطقه تكون طبعا لدينا
موقف حول المستوطنات باعتبار العقبه امام
السلام وكلنا يجب ان يعمل سويه لنمضي قدر
الامام سنبقى
طرفين ان يبقى
ملتزمين لذلك بقدر متساوي
هذا وكان الممثل الامريكي الخاص لشؤون
الفلسطينيه هادي عمرو دان اعمال العنف
والتخريب التي تعرض لها اهالي بلده حواره
جنوب مدينه نابلس على يد المستوطنين الاحد
الماضي وفي بيان نشره مكتب الشؤون
الفلسطينيه في السفاره الامريكيه في القدس
دعاها عمرو الى محاسبه ومقادات جميع
المسؤولين عن هجمات المستوطنين التي وصفها
بالشنيعه وغير المقبوله كما طالب بتعويض
الفلسطينيين الذين تضررت ممتلكاتهم واعرض
عن تعازيه في مقتل الشاب الفلسطيني
منازل وممتلكات اهالها واستمع الى شهادات
مواطنين فلسطينيين تعرضوا الاعتداءات
المستوطنين الذين هاجموا البلده بحمايه من
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انتقاما لقتل
مسلح فلسطيني مستوطنين
اسرائيليا الحديث عن ثمن باهظ هذا بحسب
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي قال ان الاحداث الاخيره كبدت اسرائيل
اثمانا كبيره هذه تحدث عن العمليات
والاحداث الاخيره وقال ان الجيش يجري
تحقيقا بشانها ويدرسها متواعدا باحباط ما
وصفه بالارهاب ايا كانت انواعه والعمل
كذلك بالوسائل العمليه والاستخباراتيه
كافه في سبيل القاء القبض على المنافدين
ولفت هذه الى ان الجيش هو المسؤول عن
الامن في الضفه الغربيه وسيحقق في اعمال
البلطجه الخطيره التي وقعت في حواره بشكل
عميق ايضا
ياتي في وقت يواصل فيه جيش الاسرائيلي طرق
او طوق امي مشدد على منطقه اريحا عقب
مستوطن في اطلاق نار بمنطقه الاغوار جنوب
البحر الميت
قوه الاحتلال نشرت حواجز عسكريه في محيط
المدينه وعززت قواتها بحثا عن مرافنين
بينما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
تواصل العمل على كافه المستويات العسكريه
والمخابراتيه بحثا عن منافذي عمليتي اطلاق
النار في حواره وفي الاغوار الجنوب اريحا
وفي سياق هذه المقاربه الامنيه للجيش
الاسرائيلي يخرج وزير الامن الداخليه
مطالبا بتغيير ما سماه مفهوم الامن
والانتقال من الدفاع الى الهجوم واضافه
بكثير في تغريده على تويتر انه لن يكون
هناك احتواء بل يد ضاربه على الحديث
التعبي
ر انعكاسات التصعيد الامير الاسرائيلي
تظهر اثارها سريعا على الارض اذا اعتقل
ثمانيه فلسطينيين على الاقل في بلده يعبد
في جنين واخرين في مخيم العروب في الخليل
جاء ذلك بعد اقتحام مخيم شعفاط في القدس
واعتقالي شاب هناك
اما في بلده جبل مكبر جنوب شقي القدس
المحتله فقد هدمت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
منزلا بحجه البناء دون ترخيص
الان بيت
للزهايكا لدار الحصري في جبل المكبر اسره
مكونه من ار
ض ومع الان من واشنطن
عضو في الحزب الديمقراطي والمبعوث الخاص
السابق للرئيس
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
مره اخرى نسمع شجبا
وتنديدا من الجانب الامريكي رغم ان
الاحداث على الارض
جعلت كثير من
المسؤوليات الفلسطينيين من الاصوات
الفلسطينيه
تشعر بغضب شديد وتطالب من المزيد
هل تعتقد انه حان الوقت لكي تقدم الولايات
المتحده المزيد في اذا كان فعلا تنوي
ايقاف هذه الاعمال
من حيث شد بها هو شعور مخلص حقيقه اعتقد
ان هناك اماكن قليله فقط بقيت في واشنطن
تستقبل او تسمحوا بذلك النوع من ردات
الفعل مثل احراقها المباني والسيارات هذا
ليس امرا اداره بالتاكيد تريد رؤيته اذا
عوده ماذا ينبغي لواء تفعل ذلك هذا السؤال
بطول الدهر نفسه نرى من وراء الكواليس
محاولات اداره بازل لايصال رساله الى
السيد نتنه بان هذا لا يمكن السكوت عنه
ولا يسمحوا او لا يمكن لان يبقى جيش
الاسرائيلي حاضر في المكان
[موسيقى]
يجب مخلص
وهنا ليس الحد ليس في ولد الحديث عن
النوايا ولكن في المقابل يعني ما يقابله
رد اسرائيلي واضح يعني الموقف ذات صعيدا
هذا ما يقول
سنضرب بيد من حديد ليس هناك
مجال التراجع من وجهه نظر اسرائيل على ما
يبدو
الى متى ستبقى الولايات المتحده صامته في
وجبات مثل هذه التصريحات التي
بطريقه او باخرى ترعاها المتحده من خلال
رعايتها ومن خلال قبولها لموقف نتنياهو
الذي يدعم
بالطبع انا افهم ان هناك
بصراحه يودون رؤيه
لاسرائيل تماما ولا تكون هناك دوله
اسرائيل على الاقل ليست دوله اسرائيل
يهوديه الوقت المتحده تدعم اسرائيل ليس
لنا دوله يهوديه ولكن لانها دوله
ديمقراطيه صراحه بصراحه بصراحه
يعني عندما يسمعك ربما كثير من العرب في
الشرق الاوسط
مثل هذه الجرائم يعني يتساءلون الى متى
فعلا ستستمر هذه النظره لاسرائيل
دعونا نضرب مثلا
تذكروا ان اسرائيل كانت تسيطر على قطاع
غزه ثم سلمته الى السلطه الفلسطينيه ماذا
كانت تداعيات
الصواريخ سقطت
نظري اسرائيل
ماذا عليهم ان يفعلوا ازاء الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هل يجب ان يسحبوا قواتهم
العسكريه ويسلمونها
وهم بذلك
قد يتعرضون لخطر الصواريخ الماضي
شكرا جزيلا
الامم المتحده
بتوفير الحمايه للسكان المدنيين
الفلسطينيين ودعا منصور مجلس الامن الدولي
الى زياره بلده حواره لكي بعينه
الانتهاكات التي وقعت هناك مضيفا انا ذلك
قد يدفع مجلس الامن نحو التطبيق العملي
لقراراته بشان الشيطان وتوفير الحمايه
للشعب
ما نريد ان نراه هو ان ندفع المجلس رويدا
رويدا خطوه خطوه الى ان يتحمل مسؤولياته
في البدء بخطوات عمليه وانا اشرت بالاجابه
على سؤال باللغه الانجليزيه
ان ارتقى حتى للحد الادنى مجلس الامن ان
يقرر ان يذهب ليرى بام عينه المجرى التي
ارتكبت
والهلع الذي اصاب السكان المدنيين في
حواره والقرى المجاوره لها انا اعتقد هذه
تكون خطوه عمليه في رؤيه الامور على الارض
كما هي
ولتصير اكثر في هذه الخطوه العمليه التي
تتحدث عنها المندوب الفلسطيني مع المقر
الامم المتحده في نيويورك مراسلنا
نعم ليلى والخطوات العمليه هي ما تسعى
اليه فلسطين والمجموعه العربيه وتحديدا من
مجلس الامن الدولي المستمر في الانعقاد
حاليا في هذه القاعه المجاوره في جلسه
مغلقه يستمع فيها الى احاطه
عمليه السلام بشان تطوراته تحديدا
الاحداث التي شهدتها نابلس المجلس
الاسرائيليه
ومرورا بما حدث في حواره واريحا وايضا
اجتماع العقبه هناك ايضا رساله فلسطينيه
من المندوب الفلسطيني وزعت على اعضاء
المجلس تضم
تفاصيل الهجمات التي قام بها عشرات
المستوطنين في حواره واحراقهم لعشرات
المنازل
وما قاموا به من عمليات تخريب واصابه
الفلسطينيين في هذه المنطقه ومطالب
بالحمايه في هذه الرساله من مصادر
دبلوماسيه ان هذه الجلسه قد تسهر عن بيان
صحفي او ما يسمى هنا في صيغه مواقع مجلس
الامن بعناصر البيان الصحفي وهي
ان درجه من المواقف الصادره عن المجلس
ولكنها تعبر عن موقف موحد لدول الاعضاء
وفي حال تم ذلك سيكون البيان الثاني بعد
البيان الذي صدر قبل اسبوع وكان بيانا
رئيسيا وهو من اقوى بيانات ومواقف مجلس
الدولي
ويعتبر من امواته الرسميه عليها
بيان وسنتابعه معك بلا شك مراد شكرا جزيلا
الى اوكرانيا الان حيث اقرا قائد القوات
البريه بان الوضع في محيط بخموت متوترا
للغايه وشرى الى انامه تستخدم وحداتها
الاكثر استعدادا لاختراق دفاعات
الاوكرانيه ومحاصره المدينه ومن جانبها
قالت ميليشيا انها سيطرت بالكامل على حي
سوكي شمال الغربي
دون خسائر
قال مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لشؤون
الشرق اسيا والمحيط الهادئ دانيال خلال
جلسه استماع في الكونغرس ان شركه الاقمار
الصناعيه الصينيه
التي تخضع لعقوبات تجاريه امريكيه وفرت
صور اقمار صناعيه من اوكرانيا لدعم ميلي
الشباب الروسيه وذلك في عملياتها القتاليه
التي تنفذها لصالح
الان الى اسيا الوسطى وصراع الفودانيه
زياره تهدف الى تعزيز تعاون الولايات
المتحده مع تلك الدول وتشجيعها على تقليص
اعتمادها الكبير على روسيا
في اسيا الوسطى معقل النفوذ الروسي المثقل
بالتاريخ والجغرافيا تدشن الولايات
المتحده جبهه التنافس جديده مع موسكو وعلى
نحو اقل مع بيجين مركز الهزه الدبلوماسيه
كان استان عاصمه كازاخستان التي زارها
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكل لكن
الارتدادات المرتقبه والمرجوه امريكيا
تشمل الى جانب كازاخستان اربع جمهوريات
سوفيات اخرى هي اوزباكستان
وتجاكستان
وتركمانستان في استناء
من الدول الخمس واكد لهم دعم بلاده
لجمهورياتهم في تعزيز سيادتها ووحده
اراضيها واستقلالها وقد بدات كازاخستان
معنيه اكثر من غيرها بحديث بلينكن
فالجمهوريه المتراميه الاطراف تتشارك مع
رو سيا حدودا بدون سبعه الاف
وخمسمائه كيلومتر وفيها اقليه روسيه كبيره
العدد
رغم نسجها تحالفات خارجيه مختلفه ظل نفوذ
موسكو فيها ساحقا الى حد ارسال العمل
الماضي قوات اليها لمساعدتها في قمع
مظاهرات ضد السلطه
وهو ارفع مسؤولين امريكي يزور اسيا الوسطى
منذ التسلم اداره بايدن السلطه جاء حاملا
الوعود والعروض لتلك العواصم التي ظلت رغم
تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي في فلك موسكو
اختيارا حينا واضطرارا في احيان كثيره
بسبب الجغرافيا وشراكات الامنيه
والاقتصاديه فهل تنجح واشنطن في الدخول
على خط الحضور الروسي القوي واغراءات
الصين الجذابه
الوزير الامريكي الذي انتقل الى
وجزباكستان بعد كازاخستان لا يبدو في مهمه
سهله غير ان اللحظه التاريخيه قد تكون
مؤاتيه اكثر من اي وقت اخر فموسكو مشغوله
بحربها على اوكرانيا وهذه الدول تزداد
هواجسها من تداعيات تلك الحرب عليها
الينا من ولايه دكتوره جعفر مرتج في
الباحثه في برنامج اسيا في مؤسسه كارانجي
والسنه العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم في
الحصاد وابدا معك سيده
هذه الزياره التي يقوم بها
سابق بلا شك يرسل رساله قويه لروسيا ما
الذي تريده فعليا واطا منها
يبدو ان الوزير بريكاني يفهم بان
الجمهوريات اسيا الوسطى
في زياد مهمه جدا في استراتيجيه الامريكيه
في اوكرانيا وفي الصين وفي افغانستان
وبالتالي الخمسه في هذه المنطقه اسيا
الوسطى يقومون الرئيسي وكبير في العديد من
الازمه قاموا بها في الانسان الماضيه في
ازمات عديده وهو يذهب الى هذه المنطقه
لمحاوله اقناع قاده عصير الوسطى بان عليهم
ان يتخذ موقفا اقوى ضد الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا ومع تاكيد لهم بانه يدعمهم
كيف تستقبل
موسكو مثل هذه الرساله الواضحه في وقت
كهذا تاخذ فيه حرب على اوكرانيا
واقع الرد فعل الرسمي
كان صامتا ذلك ان فكره ان الدول
يتخلى عن مصالحهم الاقتصاديه ويتخلوا عن
شعوب يعيشون يعملون في روسيا ويحولون
الاموال الى عوائلهم في الوطن ان يتخذوا
موقفا سياسيا يتوافق مع المصالح الامريكيه
لقائه 25 مليون دولار اعتقد هذه الفكره
بذاتها بان ان دول يمكن رشوتهم للسقوط في
خط السياسي الامريكي لاجل مصالحه هو امر
غريب وابو مثير للدهشه وفي الواقع لهذا
السبب نجد ان جديه هذه لا يكون مناقشتها
بشكل حقيقي
لمصر لذلك كان صامتا
في النهايه مثل هذه الخطوات عاده لا تنتخب
بهذا الشيء من العلانيه يعني عندما يذهب
وزير خارجيه ويزور دوله هكذا على الملا
ويعلنها يعطي المجال لتفسير من هذا النوع
الا توافقين
كانت واضحه تماما بانها تشرب بقلق
الاستقلالها وسيادتها ومثل سبب غزوه روسيا
لاوكرانيا يعطي كل الدول المنطقه وخاصه
الدول مثل الكازاخستان مصدرا لخلق الشديد
على ذلك بصراحه ولو نجحت روسيا في
اوكرانيا فالدول اسيا الوسطى يشعرون بقلق
الشديد قد يكونوا افرحيه التاليه للعدوان
الروسي وانا اتفق مع عقاله الزميلي في
موسكو
بان 25 مليون
عظيم
اقتصاديه ولكن لهذا السبب لجنه الدول هذه
المنطقه يشعرون بالقلق
روسيا على سياده سيادتهم
ان يدفع بعض الدول الى ان تغير تحالفتها
انا سعيد ان زميلتي من الولايات المتحده
من وزير خارجيه كازاخستان مختار الذي قال
نحن لا نرى ولا نشعر باي وجود اي خطر او
تهديد من روسيا في الوقت الحالي هذا لا
يبدو كانه لديه قلق شديد وبالتالي
الوسطى يفهمون بان الحرب في اوكرانيا
سببها ليس ان روسيا تريد ان تضم او تهاجم
دول هنا وهناك بل لان اوكرانيا كما قال
الرئيس بوتين او كانت تمثل خطرا واضحا
وشديدا ضد روسيا
اتفقنا ذلك غير مهم لكن المهم ان دول اسيا
يفهمون انهم غير مهددين وبالتالي سبب انا
لا اتوقع اي تغيير في التحالفات مع هذه
الدول لان قال علاقات مع روسيا لهم مفيد
للسكان كل هذه الدول الذين يعملون في
روسيا وللدول لانهم يحصلون على موالي
كثيره من التجاره بتجامته
من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا دكتور
جنافر
مرتزف فيليه الباحثه في برنامج
بعد توتر في بحر جنوب الصين والخلافات في
التجاره وملف الملكيه الفكريه نذر مواجهه
جديده بين الصين والولايات المتحده
الساحتها اليوم التكنولوجيا اذا البيت
الابيض الفيدراليه 30 يوما لكي تحضر تطبيق
تيك توك الصينيه على هواتفها واجهزتها كما
تتجه الى الغاء تراخيص منحت لشركه امريكيه
لتصدير معدات الى شركه هواوي الصينيه
تيك توك ممنوع في اجهزه امكانات الرسميه
في الولايات المتحده فالتطبيق الذي تملكه
شركه
يشكل خطرا على الامن القومي الامريكي هذه
السندجه سبق لوكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه
المتوسط اليها وحذفت من ان المخابرات
الصينيه يمكن ان تعترض بيانات مستخدمين
تيك توك
عام 2020 فهل يمكن الاستيقانون ان تجمع
بيانات المستخدمين شركه بيدن استفت مرارا
تعويضها ان مستخبي تطبيق لاي خطر لكن ما
يعزز المخاوف الامريكيه والغربيه وجود
قانون صيني دخل حادثه التنفيذ عام 2016
ويفرض القانون تحت مسمى مكافحه الارهاب
على الشركات الانترنت في الصين تسليم
مفاتيح التشهير وكلمات المرور للحكومه
الصينيه عند الطلب اضافه لقانون دخل حديث
عام 2017 ويتيح رقبه صيقه على البيانات
وتخزينها في الشركات العامله في البلاد
وبناء عليه
امريكيه من انهم مطريا
استخدام البيانات للتجسس على المستخدمين
الافراد ومراقبه نشاطهم واستهدافهم مباشره
بحمالات تضليل كما يمكن بحسب المخاوف
الامريكيه ان تستخدم بنزين البيانات
لمهاجمه الولايات المتحده بحملات لزعزعه
استقرار الحكومه الامريكيه واذا كانت
الحال مع تيك توك تتعلق بجمع البيانات لما
تحدث التعامل مع تقنيات قبل نحو عام صنفت
هيئه الاتصالات الفيدراليه في الولايات
المتحده شركه هواوي من ضمن شركات معدات
الاتصالات الصينيه التي تشكل تهديدا للامن
وتهديد الامير يكمن في اعتبار السياسيين
امريكيين شركه هواوي بمثابه ذراع تج اريه
للحزب الشيوعي الصيني اضافه الاتهامات
توجه للشركه بتنفيذ عمليات سرقه ملكيه
فكريه وامكانيه استخدام تقنيه الجيل
الخامس في التجسس وهي تقنيه
في نقل البيانات
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء نقلت
التجاره الامريكيه جينا ريموند قولها ان
الولايات المتحده تشتري اكثر من 90% من
الرقائق الالكترونيه المتقدمه من تايوان
وهي ثغره امن قومي لا يمكن الدفاع عنها
كل قطعه من المعدات العسكريه المتطوره وكل
طائره دون طيار وكل قمر اصطناعي يعتمد على
تلك الرقائق كما نقلت الصحيفه عن وثيقه
الامريكيه تتعلق بسياسات اداره بايدن حول
الرقائق ان الجيش الامريكي غير قادر حاليا
على الحصول على رقائق متطوره من مصدر
داخلي وهو ما يجعل الانظمه العسكريه
الحساسه عرضه لاضطراب
اذا بهذا تنتهي جوله الحصاد ليلى والان
موعدكم مع اللقاء اليوم وضيفه وزير خارجيه
جيبوتي محمود علي يوسف